here are this week's taught me as a  circle we can finally realize our  potential a young woman becomes  embroiled in a tech company's privacy  invading experiments in the circle does  this really seem okay to you I knew how  to work it than anyone in how to be a  Latin Lover an ageing lothario learns  the real meaning of family  everyone have a I'm just a woman's my I  this guy right what she makes a holly  you can grab it having a street magician  uses every trick up his sleeve to find  his kidnapped sister in flight these  barriers only existed let's see what's  hot in theaters with this week's  anticipation  [Music]  so what's your weekend to get going to  be let us know by commenting see you  next time on weekend ticket  [Music]